[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es mal ein richtig klassisches Rezept.
Ich werde Crème brûlée zubereiten.
Murat mag das wirklich sehr gerne.
Und ich habe Crème brûlée,
ich glaube, tatsächlich das erste Mal
sogar in Frankreich gegessen,
als wir damals den Claude besucht haben
bei de Buyer.
Es war wirklich superlecker
und vor allem ist Crème brûlée einfach sehr cremig.
Und dann hat man ja
diese karamellisierte Zuckerschicht obendrauf.
Also richtig gut!
Die Zutaten dafür habe ich persönlich immer zu Hause.
Ich brauche nämlich nur fünf
und die zeige ich euch mal kurz.
Ich nehme dafür
250 Gramm Milch,
250 Gramm Sahne,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
fünf Eigelbe
und 50 Gramm Zucker.
Die Zubereitung ist ganz einfach.
Sie ist nur etwas zeitintensiv,
weil nämlich die Crème-brûlée-Masse
gleich im Backofen stocken muss
und danach noch kühlen muss.
Aber so von der Zubereitung her wirklich supereinfach.
Ihr nehmt jetzt zuerst einmal den Zucker.
Der kommt hier in die Schüssel.
Die Eigelbe kommen dazu.
Dann etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Die Sahne und die Milch, die gebe ich jetzt hier in einen Topf.
Die erwärme ich jetzt nämlich.
Also nicht kochen lassen, nur so bis kurz vor dem Kochen.
Also mache ich jetzt hier mal Stufe 7.
Und die Eier-Zucker-Masse schön schaumig rühren.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Milchsahne so weit
und die Eiermasse auch.
Die Eiermasse ist jetzt schön weißcremig.
Und jetzt gebe ich die warme Milch
beziehungsweise die heiße Milch hier rein
während dem Rühren.
[Musik]
Ich gieße die Masse jetzt durch ein Haarsieb,
damit der Schaum verschwindet.
Ich habe nämlich etwas zu lange gerührt.
Und mit dem Messbecher
kann ich auch gleich viel einfacher einfüllen.
Ich habe jetzt keine Crème-brûlée-Schälchen.
Crème-brûlée-Schälchen sind etwas größer und flacher,
damit eben die Masse auch
schön und schnell stockt im Backofen.
Ich habe keine.
Deswegen nehme ich jetzt die Emailleschälchen.
Ihr könnt aber auch ganz einfach ein Porzellangefäß nehmen,
irgendwas, was einfach ofentauglich ist
und später beim Karamellisieren nicht kaputtgeht.
Ich habe nämlich mal den Fehler gemacht
und habe Glas genommen.
Im Backofen war alles kein Problem,
aber später, als ich dann den Gasbrenner benutzt habe,
ist das Glas gesprungen.
Und das ist halt echt schade.
Ich nehme jetzt die
und fülle sie.
Und das passt dann.
Und im Ofen muss jetzt die Masse gleich stocken.
Das heißt, die wird nicht gebacken,
sondern einfach erwärmt, dass die Eier stocken.
[Musik]
Und jetzt gebe ich sie hier in ein anderes Emailleschälchen.
Also einfach ein anderes tiefes Blech nehmen.
Denn jetzt kommen sie ins Wasserbad.
Perfekt!
Aber das Wasser gieße ich erst ein,
wenn ich sie im Ofen habe.
Bei 140°C,
das dauert so etwa 45 bis 55 Minuten.
Ihr könnt einfach mal schauen.
Sie sollen dann noch ein bisschen wacklig sein,
aber eben schon gestockt sein.
Und dann hole ich sie aus dem Backofen raus,
lasse sie komplett abkühlen.
Am besten zwei Stunden dann in den Kühlschrank stellen
nach dem Abkühlen.
Und dann kommt die Karamellschicht dran.
Und die könnt ihr wirklich wunderbar vorbereiten,
habt sie dann bereit im Kühlschrank
und kurz vor Verzehr kommt dann die Zuckerschicht.
[Musik]
Das Wasser jetzt vorsichtig eingießen,
so ungefähr halbhoch zu den Schälchen.
[Musik]
Und hier wirklich auch schon gekochtes Wasser nehmen.
Dann habt ihr das nämlich schon mal heiß.
So.
Und jetzt nur noch warten.
[Musik]
So sehen die Schälchen jetzt aus.
Wie gesagt, sind sie schon komplett abgekühlt.
Und so habe ich sie jetzt bereit.
Und wenn ihr jetzt am Tisch Crème brûlée essen möchtet,
dann kommt jetzt kurz vor Verzehr
erst die Zuckerschicht drauf,
damit sie eben noch knackig bleibt und nicht wässrig wird.
Und jetzt einfach etwas Zucker auf die Oberfläche streuen.
So eine schöne dünne Schicht.
Und dann entweder einen Gasbrenner nehmen, so wie ich,
und, wenn ihr das nicht habt,
könnt ihr auch den Backofen benutzen,
auf die höchste Grillstufe einstellen
und wirklich kurz unter der Backofen-
– wie sagt man da? –
unter dem Backofendeckel, da unter dem Dach
wirklich die oberste Einschubleiste wählen
und in den Backofen schieben.
Aber es muss wirklich ganz heiß sein
und ganz schnell gehen.
Denn die Creme unten soll ja nicht warm werden.
Es soll wirklich nur ganz kurz unter den Grill kommen.
Okay.
Simi, du bist bereit?
>> SIAMAK: Ja, ich bin bereit.
>> SALLY: Ich mache uns jetzt Crème brûlée, okay?
>> SIAMAK: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Ui!
>> SIAMAK: Mh.
>> SALLY: Es sieht schon cool aus, gell?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich finde, das muss man auch
am Tisch machen,
direkt am Tisch beim Servieren.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Woah!
Voll gut!
>> SIAMAK: Würde es auch klappen, wenn man
zum Beispiel jetzt einen Alkohol draufgibt und dann anzündet?
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> SIAMAK: Oder so was, was brennt, und dann auspusten.
>> SALLY: Das weiß ich nicht. Aber...
>> SIAMAK: Das würde auch cool aussehen,
wenn man irgendwas anzündet
und das dann oben runterbrennt.
>> SALLY: Karamellisiert es dann?
>> SIAMAK: Ich weiß es nicht.
>> SALLY: Nicht, ne?
Wahrscheinlich verbrennt dann der Alkohol und der Zucker
– aber was passiert dann mit dem Zucker?
>> SIAMAK: Aber es würde voll cool aussehen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Da haben wir immer damals im Chemieunterricht,
da hat unser Chemielehrer damals,
der Herr Dr. Dumm
– der hieß so!
Ich wollte ihn gerade grüßen
und jetzt lachst du ihn einfach aus.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, okay.
>> SALLY: Hallo, Herr Dr. Dumm!
Ich war
– ich kenne Sie noch. Ich war eine gute Chemieschülerin.
Ich bin nur zweimal aus dem Chemieunterricht abgehauen
über die
Brandschutztür.
Aber er hat es nicht gemerkt.
Aber ich habe es ihm danach irgendwann erzählt.
Und er so: "Oh, hoppala! Das habe ich gar nicht gemeint."
Okay, es war...
So was macht man nicht!
Ja.
Aber wir haben gewettet, ob er es merkt oder nicht.
Er hat es nicht gemerkt.
>> SIAMAK: Ich lasse es, was ich gerade sagen wollte.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und ich war eine gute Chemieschülerin.
Ja.
Und dann hat er da
– ah ja, genau. Ah, ich bin voll abgewichen.
Und dann hat er immer
– der hat auch so eine Steinplatte gehabt im Chemielabor.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann hat er da auch einfach
immer Alkohol draufgeschüttet und angebrannt.
Dann haben wir immer so zugeguckt.
Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es war schon...
Okay.
>> SIAMAK: Und alle so: "Woah!"
>> SALLY: Was wolltest du sagen?
>> SIAMAK: Ich wollte sagen, ich würde gerne probieren.
>> SALLY: Ach so? Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Darf ich?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Du kannst den Messlöffel nehmen.
>> SIAMAK: Ach so!
>> SALLY: Ich würde ihn nicht nehmen.
>> SIAMAK: Ich dachte gerade, das wäre ein Löffel.
Ich habe gar nicht darauf geachtet.
Ups!
>> SALLY: Der Messlöffel.
Da kommst du halt so schlecht...
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, aber
– das muss nämlich ganz kurz abkühlen.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ah, doch. Das ist schon...
>> SIAMAK: Aber es ist schon hart. Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ja!
>> SIAMAK: Das zerbreche ich immer,
zum Spaß immer.
>> SALLY: So muss es knacken!
Ich sehe schon.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Juhu!
>> SIAMAK: Ja, die Zuckerschicht oben ist immer so geil!
>> SALLY: Die ist die beste.
Mmh!
Und unten dann so schön kühl.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> SIAMAK: Oben noch ein kleines bisschen warm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Und unten kommt echt das Kühle durch.
>> SALLY: Voll gut und richtig cremig!
Und ich finde, es schmeckt auch echt leicht, gell?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Es ist zwar Sahne drin, aber...
Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Kalorien hast du eh gerade verbrannt.
Von daher...
>> SALLY: Meine Worte.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Oh, ist das lecker!
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
Crème brûlée ist einfach so lecker!
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was ich noch nie gesehen habe?
Eine Schoko-Crème-brûlée.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, stimmt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Also Schokopudding wäre es dann, so ähnlich.
>> SALLY: Hm. Und dann statt Vanilleextrakt mit Tonka.
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Müsste man mal auch mal ausprobieren.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Jedenfalls habt ihr hier
das klassische Crème brûlée.
Probiert es gerne aus.
Ihr habt gesehen, schwierig ist es nicht.
Ihr müsst nur ein bisschen Zeit mitbringen.
Aber man kann das auch supergut vorbereiten,
auch am Tag vorher
und dann am nächsten Tag einfach nur noch karamellisieren.
Also probiert es gern mal aus.
Und
du sagst mir gleich, was du wirklich sagen wolltest.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
>> SIAMAK: Tschüss!
[Musik]